[Music]
hey let's go great boom star hmm I'm not
going out what you looking like that
come on quit like a [ __ ] okay stop
oh that works Lulu stop I am NOT as if
anything I am oh not that I'm a weight
classier version of that are you really
I am a snoot what's a sloop that is
where the Queen of England has confirmed
that it is a lady of the night that
patrols the streets and looks for her
knight in shining armor and that is a
classy sleep time as I don't care what
you want to call flute [ __ ] and the S is
accent with the mighty s small s capital
s I don't care I'm not going out what
you looking like that okay fine I'll go
change
oh I can see your booty hall in those
leg ins
did you get that bleached looks good
thanks
$5.99 on eBay
[Music]
yeah why you don't like a little house
on a prairie see your neck it's going
backwards on this one
my neck is covered
Oh
yeah
perfect yes perfect
you ready
[Music]
damn girl you can't keep the clothes off
on one second
I didn't even I really am the biggest
Sloot I know slept and yes you are no
you are no I can't be a [ __ ]
I have a boyfriend it's the rules how do
people know you're taken well you know
how i 100% believe in labels and titles
and all that good stuff right yes I
really feel like it's just the
unemotional vibe I give off like don't
touch me
yeah you know what I kind of feel it you
feel it right it's like cold and dusty
please that's me cold and dusty yeah
it's good thing I wear a jacket good
thing this Kabbalah
okay do their vegetable ones I hate you
I am hungry they all get some like tater
tots or something too
[Music]
little why is everybody asking so rude I
notice neighborhoods too nice for you to
be standing on the corner like a sweet
me the street it's clear let's go oh
look who's in charge now
look it's just this are your trouble
thank you
let's go over here there's probably more
[ __ ] like you down there yeah thank you
God that was close yeah let's go hungry
I'm so hungry right what do you want is
something Joe chicken sandwich you [ __ ]
it's an ex-boyfriend yeah I knew I came
to trust you with girls - you're
cheating [ __ ] you're my ex-boyfriend I
don't care you're slacking imma trust
you I was paying her oh gosh that's a
[ __ ] thing that's a thing there was
the Queen of England and there's Knights
and there's like streetwalkers it's okay
yeah but you're still [ __ ] a minute
nerve you know what dilute shaming is
not about a woman's sexuality it's just
grounded in the belief that men get to
assert themselves and women do not yeah
it's just getting a lot of attention
lately just so people can just signifies
some old-fashioned sexism mmm oh my god
I'm so sorry you're not a [ __ ] thank you
sir
no you're a [ __ ]
yeah you should
[Music]